when getting started with gke it's
essential to think about how you can
design for security across multiple
dimensions
today let's review the first areas
you'll need to consider when securing
access to your gk cluster
[Music]
it's important to start with defining
what cluster access means
with gke there are two dimensions in
which we access our cluster
the first dimension is the gke api
this is where users can perform cluster
operations
rather than creating kubernetes
resources we use the gke api to create
read update and delete gke clusters
the second dimension is the kubernetes
control plane
this is how we create read update and
delete kubernetes resources in a gke
cluster
across both the gke api and the
kubernetes control plane we want to
ensure that users only have the access
they need and nothing more
this is called the principle of least
privilege
let's review the various knobs we have
available in gke to develop a strategy
to achieve this
accessing a gke cluster starts with gcp
identity and access management or iam
like most gcp services gke is tightly
integrated with gcp iam
in gke roles and permissions can be
assigned to individual users or an
entire google group
this can help greatly as the surface of
your team changes over time one of the
quickest ways to get started with
accessing gke is using gcp iam's
predefined roles
in gke there are predefined roles such
as admin developer viewer all of which
can be assigned to user accounts or
google group using gcp iam
it is important to note that the role
will apply
to all gke clusters in a gcp project
once assigned a predefined role users
will have a set of permissions that
authorize them
to interact with the gke api
this means that they can perform
operations that align with their role
whether it's creating a cluster adding a
node pool or manually triggering a
cluster upgrade
these predefined roles also give users
authorization to perform various actions
when interacting with the kubernetes api
again it is important to note that not
only does this apply to all clusters in
a project but all name spaces within a
gke cluster
now this can be really convenient
especially if you're a team doing your
own development and your own operations
gke's integration with gcp iam can be a
single method for configuring access to
both the gke api and kubernetes
resources within your gke clusters
however if we need more granular control
to achieve the principle of least
privilege we'll have to be a bit more
intentional configuring gcp iam in
kubernetes role based access control or
rbac in concert with one another
we can start by looking at creating a
custom gcp iam role
rather than utilizing the predefined
roles that gke provides we can consider
creating a custom gcp iam role with
lesser permissions
we can then use kubernetes rbac to
define user access when interacting with
the kubernetes control plane in a gke
cluster
kubernetes rbac allows us to enable
granular control over what spaces and
what kubernetes resources that users can
interact with on a per cluster basis
an example of this in action would be to
define a gcp iam custom role for users
that don't need to manage the gke
cluster life lifecycle but do need to
interact with the kubernetes control
plane for various clusters in their
project
in this scenario the custom role would
be minimal only allowing the user get
permissions with the gke api which
enables them to get their credentials to
access the kubernetes control plane but
by default this would not give them
permissions to actually perform any
actions against the kubernetes control
plane
instead any permissions when interacting
with the kubernetes control plane would
be defined in kubernetes rbac
which can give us the granularity we
need to achieve the principle of least
privilege now once we have found the
right balance of our gcp iam roles and
utilizing kubernetes rbac
gke provides another layer for us to
secure cluster access
this time around a user's network
identity
even if a user is already set up with
gcp iam
are back correctly
we may also want to verify the network
from which they are running
in gke authorized networks is a feature
that allows us to only enable
communication with the kubernetes
control plane in our gke clusters from a
trusted set of ip addresses
this adds an additional layer of
security to not only ensure that our
user is authorized to perform a certain
set of actions but is also performing
these actions from a trusted network
perimeter to recap configuring gcp iam
kubernetes rbac and gke authorized
networks is a great place to start when
building a gke cluster that adheres to
your organization's security best
practices
now that we've covered the essentials
for securing cluster access in gke visit
the links here to learn more
with the concepts discussed in this
video we're confident you'll be on your
way to building a gke cluster that suits
your needs stay tuned as we expand on
other gk topics in gke essentials
you